hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer questions
from one of my forum leader Sophia who
wrote in about help desk software for
her new business and one of my advice so
she wrote in saying I'm running a small
business online now and I really do not
want to do too much one-on-one customer
service can I use a customer service
support software what is the best
customers for software online how can I
use it please help I saw one last night
called I code I code helpdesk X I want
to buy it not sure whether it works
please give me some you so advise thank
you so much so Sophia thanks for the
question I haven't heard of that that
software before but I'll trying to give
you a couple tips that might help you
solve this challenge the first stop if
you're running any kind of online
business you want to make the experience
as simple as possible so that you don't
have a lot of customer complaints or
questions I you know for the people who
do have problems and right in there's
ten times the amount who never right in
and just abandon your site so if it's
really complicated then they're going to
leave on my first software company I was
a bona fide software company we didn't
have the most features but ours was the
easiest software to use on the market
and that got us a lot of attention a lot
of customers and we didn't have to do a
lot of support which also helped us be
able to build up our business and get
more customers as well so whatever it is
that you're doing online you want to try
to make it as easy as possible for your
customers to take the next step so they
don't have to write in and and you know
ask questions on what to do next so that
being said assume when you're ready
doing that you're still going to have
some people who have problems so what
you do is the next step my suggests will
not be to use a software company reason
being when you're in start-up mode you
want to get as close to your customers
as possible so people are having
problems you want to be able to answer
those questions really quickly respond
quickly be able to make fixes you know
as quick as you can the
one thing that differentiates a small
start-up from a big company is
flexibility and speed so you want to
take advantage of that you want to wait
a long time to get back to people if
you're finding people asking similar
questions or having problems with
something you want to make a change
right away and try to keep that customer
as long as you can make them happy and
if you can overturn a bad situation to a
positive you're more likely to keep that
customer for a long term and also
they're going to tell their friends but
the great experience I had nobody goes
and tells a friends about the great
experience it had used in a customer
service software online right it's from
the personal touch they get from dealing
with people at the company so especially
when you're in start-up mode I would not
use a software company I would try to do
it personally get the feedback from the
customers build closer relationships and
be able to take the feedback to give you
to make your product better as you grow
I then would look at delegating that so
having somebody on the team and on my
team I don't so we have six thousand
people who write for my website I am NOT
managing those relationships I used to
and then I took just took up way too
much of my time so I brought on somebody
and that's her main functions to work
with our authors and answer their
questions and build new innovations to
help them out and so you want to have
somebody who is responsive in an ideal
world kind of give your options you can
look at even a place like odesk calm to
try to find people to help on the
support site at hopefully are maybe a
cheaper rate then you would get locally
if budget is a really big issue for you
if you absolutely have to have to have
to get a software I'd look at zendesk
I've heard some good things about it I
haven't used it personally but there is
a free trial so that will let you test
things out to see if you like it or not
that would be you know my my suggestion
for the start for most of these online
software tools there usually is a free
trial so you should be able to check it
out test it see if it works and see if
it solves your needs and then make a
decision to a bind or not I'd be worried
about something I just asked you to make
a commitment up front so i would
definitely check out zen
I have no affiliation with them other
than I've heard a few good things about
them but again if you could I try to do
everything yourself personally at the
beginning to get the feedback to make it
so easy to use it you don't have a lot
of customer feedback and then as you
grow having somebody else on your team
be responsive provide awesome service is
that's how you're going to be able to
stand out compared to the more
established competitors so hopefully
that helps Afiya maybe not quite the
answer you wanted to hear but that's
what I think so hopefully like that
gives you something to think about so
those watching the video if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more videos like
this for you guys and if you have a
comment about this video or a question
of your own about your business feel
free to leave it in the comment section
below and I read every one and do my
best to answer everybody so thank you
and we'll see you on the next episode
you